new numbers now from the Department of
Labor show us that employers made fewer
hires last month a hundred and thirty
thousand new jobs were added in August
that is below the six-month average of a
hundred and fifty thousand but the
unemployment rates stayed the same three
point seven percent which is near the
lowest level in five decades and those
who did work earned more money the
average pay increased by three point two
percent compared to one year ago the
slowdown in hiring may be due to a
weakening global economy and president
Trump's ongoing trade war with China
those are some of the many issues on the
President's agenda when Congress returns
from its August recess on Monday we J
Jiang is at the White House we jug good
morning what else does the president
want lawmakers to take on right now oh
good morning Dana President Trump has a
long wish list that includes passing an
immigration bill to build his border
wall ratifying the u.s. MCA which is
that North American trade deal that
would replace NAFTA and achieving an
infrastructure bill and even though a
White House official tells CBS News the
president wants to take quote meaningful
actions to address mass shootings and
reduce gun violence the president
continues to be vague this week he kept
the focus on mental illness and said new
institutions have to be opened to treat
those impacted before Congress went on
break mr. Trump called for meaningful
background checks but now he says
comprehensive ones would not have
stopped recent mass shootings and he is
looking at several other options in fact
President Trump said he heard 29
different proposals after having
meetings and phone calls with various
lawmakers during a radio interview
Senate Majority Leader Mitch McConnell
said he would be happy to put a gun
reform bill on the floor if President
Trump took a clear position on it but so
far he has not said exactly what he is
willing to support Jeff okay lots of
cover there which also it seems the the
president's feud with Noah Bazar feud
would know it took another turn last
night what is the latest with that yes a
Noah issued a statement that said the
information it gave President Trump over
the weekend did in fact include Alabama
in its projections it also disavowed a
tweet that was sent out on Sunday by the
Birmingham
the National Weather Service that said
Alabama would not be impacted and in
another dramatic twist the president of
the National Weather Service Employees
organization fired back calling that
NOAA statement quote utterly disgusting
and disingenuous this comes after the
president took heat for several days
after showing off a map in the Oval
Office that appeared to alter the
projection map to include Alabama as for
visiting the area nothing is on his
official schedule yet but he has
traveled to storm-ravaged places in the
past in sources him say he could do that
again we do know he will be close to
Dorian's path on Monday night he is
holding a campaign rally in Fayetteville
North Carolina which is just about 200
miles from the state's hurricane
battered coast ok we do jenk thank you
very much